WE'RE GONNA GET STARTED HERE
THIS IS THE CALIFORNIA STATE
SENATE COMMITTEE AND ENERGY
ENERGY UTILITIES AND
COMMUNICATIONS WE'RE GONNA
START AS A SUBCOMMITTEE ALL OF
THE COMMITTEE TO HEAR TESTIMONY
ON SB FIVE FIFTY BY SENATOR
HILL. SO WE'LL GET STARTED
CENTER HER WELCOME THANK YOU
VERY VERY MUCH RICHER SB FIVE
FIFTY PROVIDES ADDITIONAL
CRITERIA FOR THE CPUC TO
CONSIDER IN REVIEWING A
PROPOSED CORPORATE
RESTRUCTURING TO ENSURE SAFE
SERVICE OF THE SUCCESSOR
ENTITY. ADDITIONALLY AMENDMENTS
TAKEN IN THE ASSEMBLY CLARIFY
THE CPUC REVIEW PROCESS BETWEEN
I USED END OF PUBLIC ENTITIES
IS RELATED TO WORK FORCE AND
RATE PAYER IMPACTS THESE
AMENDMENTS ARE IMPORTANT
CLARIFICATIONS NEGOTIATED AFTER
THE PASSAGE OF AB TEN FIFTY
FOUR EARLIER THIS YEAR THIS
BILL HAS RECEIVED BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT. AS NO OPPOSITION I
RESPECTFULLY ASK DR COLLEAGUES
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE HAVE AYE
LOOKING. APPEARS THAT WE HAVE A
QUORUM CLERK COULD YOU PLEASE
CALL. NO WE DON'T WANT WOMEN
WHOSE YEAH WE DO I'M HERE.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. WHEN THEY
GOT HERE. HUESO. ISN'T PRESENT
MOORLACH BRADFORD. BRADFORD
HERE KING KING HERE DODD DIED
HERE HERTZBERG HILL YOUR HILL
HERE MCGUIRE MCGUIRE HERE RUBIO
RUBIO HERE SKINNER STERN STONE
WIENER. VERY WELL OF DO WE HAVE
A SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT GERMAN
MEMBERS WE HAVE THE CITY AND
COUNTY SAN FRANCISCO ON BEHALF
WITH RESPECT TO THE NEWS
PROVISIONS THE BILL VERY
GRATEFUL TO A LOT OF MEMBERS
AND STAFF. FOLKS DOWNSTAIRS THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE AND
ESPECIALLY CENTER HELL FOR
ALLOWING IT IN INTO THE BILL SO
THANK YOU AND I JUST REQUEST AN
AYE VOTE. A MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS DON GILBERT WITH.
REPRESENTING SAM CISCO PUBLIC
UTILITIES COMMISSION ECHOING
MISTER YODER'S COMMENTS AND
THANKING THE AUTHOR AS WELL.
CAN ANYONE ELSE TO HAVE ANY
OPPOSITION. CAN I GET ANYBODY
TO VOLUNTEER TO OPPOSE THIS
BILL HEY HEY HEY. I WILL COME
TO MEMBERS FOR COMMON CENTER
DOT YES SCENARIO I I'VE I'VE
GOT I'D LIKE A KIND OF A
STATEMENT HERE THAT I JUST WANT
ONE A RE BECAUSE I WANT TO MAKE
SURE I GET ALL ALL THESE POINTS
THE MATTER RECORD OP DON'T
MIND. SO YOU KNOW IS WE'VE
TALKED AND I'M CONCERNED ABOUT
PARTS LAYING OUT THE TRANSFER
OF UTILITY ASSETS. IN CUSTOMER
BASE TO ANY PARTY AND THE
IMPACT THAT THAT'LL HAVE ON
ELECTRIC RATES. A REAM FOR
REMAINING CUSTOMERS THAT THEY
WILL HAVE TO BEAR SHOULD A
TRANSFER KIRK I FURTHER CONCERN
ON HOW THE TRANSFER OF AFTER
ASSETS A CUSTOMER BASE WILL
CHANGE THE UTILITIES REVENUE
STREAM. IMPACTING THE ABILITY
OF THE CORPORATION TO MAKE THE
NECESSARY INVESTMENTS TO
UPGRADE ITS INFRASTRUCTURE AND
ALSO ACHIEVED A GREAT HARDENING
COMMITMENTS MADE IN THE
UTILITIES WHILE FIRE MITIGATION
PLANS. I PERSONALLY THE
CONVERSATIONS THAT WE'VE HAD
EARLIER THIS WEEK AND I WILL
MAKE THE MOTION HERE TO
ADVANCES BILL BUT AND WILL VOTE
ON THE FLOOR TODAY. BUT I WANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE HAVE
ASSURANCES FROM YOU AND THE
OTHER I I'VE HEARD FROM OTHER
RATE. THE RATE PAYER GROUPS.
ADD TO THE CPUC ALREADY DOES
HAVE A PROCESS THAT WASN'T
NECESSARY YOU KNOW IN THE BILL
THAT WAS PASSED EARLIER THIS
YEAR THERE ALREADY IS A PROCESS
TO MAKE SURE THE RATE PAYERS.
ULTIMATELY ARE PROTECTED IN
THIS REGARD ANY COMMENTS ON THE
AND THEY IN MISTER CHAIR IF I
MADE THE THANK YOU FOR THAT AND
I ENJOYED OUR CONVERSATIONS
APPRECIATE THE CONCERN BECAUSE
THAT REALLY. HAVE A LOT TO DO
WITH MY SUPPORT IN EFFORTS
AROUND TEN FIFTY FOUR EARLIER
THIS YEAR WERE THOSE
CONVERSATIONS THAT WE HAD I
THINK WHAT WOULD MADE THIS.
COMFORTABLE FOR ME WAS THE
ASSURANCE THAT HISTORICALLY THE
PC PC HAS THAT ABILITY AND HAS
THAT ROLE AND RESPONSIBILITY
AND I GUESS WHAT WOULD IT'S OUR
RESPONSIBILITY AS- OVERSEERS OF
THAT WHEN AND. IF THERE IS A-
MUNICIPAL PURCHASE OR. WHICH IS
IN THAT EXCHANGE SO. I THINK
IT'S A- THIS BILL DOES NOT
CHANGE THAT. AND I THINK IT'S
OUR RESPONSIBILITY TO MAKE SURE
THAT IT IS ENFORCED AND CARRIED
OUT IN THE FUTURE THANK CENTER
MOVE THE BILL. WELL WE HAVE A
MOTION ANYONE ELSE FROM THE
COMMITTEE WISH TO SPEAK. DID
YOU WANNA MAKE ANY CLOSING
COMICALLY ASTEROID I HAVE A
COLLEAGUE THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THANK YOU FOR YOUR
HELP MISTER CHAIR PLEASE CALL
VOTE. THE ASSEMBLYMEMBERS
BECAME KURT IN HUESO. WITH SO I
MORE LOT. MORE LIKE AYE
BRADFORD. BRADFORD I CHING
CHANG AYE DODD. DODD AYE
HERTZBERG AYE HILL AYE HILL AYE
MCGUIRE. WHERE I RUBIO RUBIO
AYE SKINNER STERN STERN AYE
STONE AYE STONE AYE WIENER
WIENER AYE. THE HOLDER ROLE
OPEN FOR OF THE NUMBERS. WE
HAVE ONE TWO THANK YOU GUYS ALL
RIGHT ARE THEY COMING. BRING
THEM. GERMAN MEDIA. I'M JUST
GRATEFUL TO BE OF. NUMBER.
WHERE HE'S RIGHT THERE THERE
SKINNER STUFF THAT WE'RE GONNA
GO AHEAD AND TURN NOW. THIS
COMMITTEE IS ADJOURNED. OKAY
ENERGIES OUT